[Music]
from the Michael Bay of the 80s but
better comes a film that combines the
best action the best horror and the best
handshake in all of human history you
son of a [ __ ] so does anyone else grow
a mustache every time they watch that
predator deep in the heart of the
Central American jungle where no one can
hear you sweat profusely something is
hunting men for sport and that something
would have been an awesome mystery if
they didn't show a spaceship in the
first scene it's an alien besides them
yep
alien saw the ship something out there
waiting force under they know man okay
fine I'll do it you two comments do
movie starts at 1 minute 29 seconds join
an elite squad of assassins reah rescue
team not assassins stick around there's
Billy the jacked up macho Native
American plane the jecht of macho
redneck Mac and Dylan the checked up
macho black eyes poncho the jacked-up
macho Latino Hawkins the screenwriter
they wanted on set for Punjab and their
leader Dutch eject up bad a
cigar-chomping Kevin McCallister
[Music]
come on kill me I'm here keep the change
you filthy animal yeah thrill as they're
up against the ultimate enemy
jean-claude Van Damme and a stupid
lobster costume yep that really happened
but once he got fired they went up
against the real ultimate enemy the
predator a perfect mix of Awesome
creature design as in a mesh bodysuit
and Vincent Price laughs who uses
advanced technology to hunt the
equivalent of fish in a barrel
yeah I guess he's less cool when you
realize he's like those yuppies who
shoot two rats with a sniper rifle
so before you see the predator revisit
the predator that's never been improved
on and it's sequels and could be
re-released in theaters today because
it's aged so well bunch of swamp Jordan
mostly well because in an action horror
movie this good with so many iconic
lines I ain't got time to be and such an
iconic booby monster you'll barely even
notice that half the film is just
quietly looking at trees
[Music]
something in those trees it's an alien
story the future Governor of California
the future governor of Minnesota a
future candidate for governor of
Kentucky okay this is getting weird
maybe you've got a stupe going to
moisturize the director of iron man 3
and I gotta get to the job of my skull
my back my trophy in my pack
and the end credits that make the movie
look like a 90s sitcom
[Music]
[Applause]
Austrian versus Predator
my main another expendable
you changed Arnold you changed there's
nothing sadder than an empty pizza box
hello you son of a [ __ ] 10-4 good buddy
you have failed me for the last time a
troll get to the chopper